the crowds are descending for the cop 26
u.n climate summit in glasgow the
world's last best chance to limit global
warming
but its prospects haven't been helped by
a lack of real progress on cutting coal
and carbon emissions at the g20 summit
in rome a frustrated boris johnson
piling on the pressure this is very very
urgent for
not just for our country for the whole
world and if i had to give a comparison
it was a one minute to midnight moment
and
the
the clock is is is ticking we have to
get uh everybody to do more we've made
some progress at the at the g20 there's
no doubt about it
cop 26 president alok sharma is pushing
for more from every nation but it's
tough going are you worried well look um
we've got the world leaders summit
taking place and this is an opportunity
for them to rise to the occasion to come
forward with those commitments and at
the end of the day it's world leaders
who committed in paris to limit global
temperature rises and now in glasgow
they have to deliver the reality is that
the key aim of the summit keeping 1.5
degrees of warming within reach is
hanging in the balance
there is still a long list of
complicated issues that need sorting out
more ambition to reduce harmful
emissions a global agreement on carbon
markets more protection for forests more
cash for developing nations all of these
things need agreement if this summit is
to be deemed a success
the uk will promise more funding for
climate vulnerable countries it still
won't be enough
we are at a crossroads
fork in the road
either we pay up or we perish
and
if we are thinking for some reason
one segment will perish another will be
saved
we are deluding ourselves
because we are
facing this existential problem together
as glasgow gets underway boris johnson
will warn the time to act is now
most gathered here will agree the future
of the planet depends on it
hannah thomas peter sky news at cop 26
in glasgow